Поки в Україні лише готуються до відкриття ринку землі, Німеччина давно є прикладом того,
як можна цивілізовано його організувати.
Тут рілля вільно продається і є товаром, який дорожчає з року в рік.
Скільки коштує купівля та оренда німецької землі, як убезпечують ринок від спекулянтів
та як живеться фермерам у ФРН, пропоную розібратися у цій серії.
Поговоримо про німецьку землю з тими, хто щодня на ній працює.
Себастіан Лумер - 26-річний фермер у третьому поколінні.
З 1984 року фермерське господарство його батька було сертифіковане як органічне.
Себастіан причепив плуг до трактора. Сьогодні він має орати поле на якому росла люцерна.
Це поле орендоване, воно мені не належить. Це значить, що ми платимо річну оренду, аби мати право його обробляти.
Це не громадська, а приватна земля.
Себастіан платить за оренду одного гектара - 350 євро на рік.
Середня вартість оренди гектара ріллі у Німеччині 2016 року становила 328 євро.
А десять років тому гектар орендували майже на сто євро дешевше - за 230 євро.
Раніше тут було більше фермерів. Зараз ці люди не займаються сільським господарством,
однак вони або їхні діти все ще є власниками цієї землі. Вони здають свою землю в оренду іншим фермерам.
Щороку зростає не лише орендна плата, а і вартість купівлі ріллі.
У землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія, де розташоване господарство Себастіана,
2019 року гектар у середньому можна було придбати за майже 54 тисячі євро.
Три роки тому було на 5 тисяч дешевше. Ще дорожча рілля у ФРН лише в Баварії:
65 тисяч за гектар, найдешевша у землі Cаарланд - трохи менше 10 тисяч євро за гектар.
Я обробляю майже 90 гектарів землі. З них у власності моєї родини перебуває лише 12-13 гектарів, це у порівнянні досить мало.
Ті, хто мають землю, переважної її не продають, бо ціна постійно росте, ділянка може стати землею під забудову,
а зазвичай у вас є шанс придбати ділянку землі лише раз у житті.
З 17 млн га земель сільськогосподарського призначення у ФРН майже 60 відсотків перебувають в оренді.
Змінити призначення землі, за німецькими законами, може землевпорядний орган.
До прикладу, оці поля роками орендував у міста Трір для вирощування овочів і фруктів фермер Ганс-Йозеф Ґрайф.
З ним ми познайомилися в серії про спаржу. Однак нещодавно мережа роздрібної торгівлі запропонувала місту звести тут супермаркет.
Після громадських слухань депутати ухвалили рішення на користь магазину, мотивуючи це інтересами громади.
Адже від супермаркету очікують створення нових робочих місць та сплати податків у місцевий бюджет.
Тож фермерові доведеться вирощувати полуниці деінде.
Звичайно ж, Німеччина відома на весь світ своїм пивом, а також вином сорту Рислінг.
Виноград для цього вина вирощують саме на цих схилах, на березі річки Мозель. Пропоную спуститися туди вниз
і поговорити з власниками винарень – кому належить земля під цими виноградниками.
Це винарня Ґеорґа Фрітца фон Неля. Родина фон Нелів з 17 століття займалася торгівлею деревини.
У 1803 році Наполеон завоював Мозельський Регіон. Виноградники, що належали церкві, виставили на продаж.
Фон Нелі, які заробили статки на деревині, вклали їх у виноградники, і відтоді вже сьоме покоління виробляють власне вино.
За двісті з гаком років змінювалися уряди та епохи,
а виноградники родини фон Нель залишалися недоторканною приватною власністю.
У нас у приватній власності приблизно 16 гектарів виноградників. Ще чотири гектари ми орендуємо.
Зазвичай, якщо у вас сімейне підприємство, всі діти мають право отримати свою частку.
Однак часто для збереження господарства, щоб його не робивати на шматки і щоб його легше було обробляти
і це економічно було вигідно, право наслідування отримує старший син.
Виноградар ще міркує, кому з двох синів передати виноградники дідів-прадідів.
До речі, у Східній Німеччині, яка пережила 45 років радянської окупації і соціалістичного експерименту,
проблематика спадку землі дещо інша.
У деяких федеральних землях колишньої НДР нащадки власників, які втратили свої землі під час колективізації,
до 2009 року могли придбати ці ділянки за 65 відсотків ринкової вартості.
Для цього фермерам спочатку треба було довести належне виконання обов’язків щодо оренди цих земель
протягом шести років та виконати ще низку умов. Ось такий спадок укрупнення господарств за часів НДР.
Ґеорґу Фрітцу фон Нелю укрупнюватися нікуди, бо сусіди - такі ж родини виноробів і землі не продають.
Саме тому він вклав кошти в оптимізацію того, що в нього є. Три роки тому чоловік викорчував всю стару лозу на горі
і насипав тераси - тепер можна працювати з технікою, а не лише руками. Ось так виноградники виглядають зараз.
Тут у мене виноград сорту Рислінг. Треба щонайменше п'ять років, аби лоза почала давати врожай.
Тепер нахил гори максимум 6 градусів. А раніше був 78 градусів.
А це проліт над виноградниками Бернда Фукса, що за 30 кілометрів від винарні Ґеорґа Фрітца фон Неля.
Вся родина Фукс за роботою: дід, батько і сини збирають врожай.
У будь-який час до них може завітати інспекція від Сільськогосподарської палати.
Вони перевіряють, чи вирощують фермери саме те, що зазначили у документах.
Звичайно, тут, на сланцевих ґрунтах, де з часів Римської імперії росте лише виноград, жито не засієш.
Тож більшу увагу контролери поділяють вимірювання меж і площі господарства з джипіес-трекерами.
Якщо фермер має органічне господарство, перевіряють чи дотримується він усіх вимог.
Розраховують навіть середній рівень викидів СО2.
На виноградниках Фукса багато ручної праці, хіба що ось ці музейного вигляду трактори ці трохи псують повітря.
Трактор "Айхер" 1957 року випуску. Його потужність – 26 кінських сил. Для нашого господарства він добре підходить.
Після високотехнологічних сучасних тракторів на ріллі у Себастіана Лумера, я був вражений побачити
у робот і на виноградниках трактори, яким 63 роки. Вони прості і не мають електроніки, тож фермер ремонтує їх у гаражі сам.
Вайнґут Фукс - маленьке господарство - трьох тракторів цілком достатньо.
Ми володіємо трьома з половиною гектарами виноградників - це наша приватна власність.
А чи можна в наш час ще докупити землі?
Так, це завжди можливо. Часто фермери цікавляться сусідніми ділянками, хто що має, аби розширити своє господарство.
Ціна залежить від місця розташування ділянки – в середньому це 3-4 євро за квадратний метр.
Іноземцям та громадянам країни дозволено купувати і продавати землю у ФРН без обмежень.
Це можуть бути як фізичні, так і юридичні особи. Німецьке законодавство не встановлює мінімального терміну оренди
і водночас перешкоджає надмірній експлуатації родючості ґрунтів.
Так у документах оренди фермер зазначає, що саме вирощуватиме, і не повинен порушувати домовлений перелік.
Також необхідно дотримуватися сівообороту, тобто не сіяти два роки поспіль культури, що виснажують землю.
Прозорість ринку землі забезпечують незалежні комісії експертів-оцінювачів, які щорічно оновлюють бази даних
цін на земельні ділянки. Моніторинг цін протидіє спекулятивним угодам на основі заниження
або завищення реальної вартості сільськогосподарської землі.
А мозельські винороби місцеві сланцеві грунти називають безцінним капіталом
і з радістю пропонують скуштувати плоди їхньої праці.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще вам цікаво дізнатися про Німеччину і я розповім вам про це у наступні серії. Побачимось!